right so I had the planner I open it up
and I look at the back of it and it's
like okay you need 21 credit hours to
graduate and I didn't say what they hope
they were but it's just said you need 21
and I had 20.5 or something like that
someone to the counselor and I was like
hey I have 20.5 could I go to summer
school and graduate in she was like no
absolutely not and I was like but it
says right here and then of course my
parents back me up on that so I was able
to like kind of nobody would think to do
that out not very many people like I
don't think would think to figure out
how to do that but I don't like when
people tell me what to do so I just
figured out a way to do it the way I
wanted to do it it's kind of how I lived
a lot of my early childhood and in life
in general I guess I think you have to
have a little bit of that in order to
navigate your way around these parts in
LA and Hollywood it's a tough game
otherwise how so get beat around you
know you can't beat up and shoved aside
and you know people tell you know all
the time and I found no one was ever
going to give me the opportunity I had
to take it so one of the first movies I
ever did out in LA of my own I got a
bunch of my friends together who were
still in college I graduated you early
because I was ahead of a lot of them
because of the high school thing and
they had that summer and I knew what my
summer was like right after you
graduated sort of like what do I do now
there's not a whole lot of commitments
you have a lot of time most people don't
have a full-time job yet but sooner or
later they're all going to get that or
they're going to go off and start living
their adult lives well I saw a key
opportunity to to get a lot of my old
movie making friends back together and
take that short period of time that none
of us would ever get back again and try
to do something with it something that
we would all be able to benefit from and
that would be that was making a feature
films my first film that nobody knows
about it's called finger man dr. London
in the Triangle force that's actually my
first feature film although compound is
being sort of
presented as my first my directorial
debut with finger man was actually my
first feature film and it was a major
collaborative effort with a lot of my
good friends from back in the day Chris
Cowan Dan Davidson scheming Woolery
Steve Murray fonsella card or no
Applebaum James Flynn like these are my
really good friends from back in the day
that we all came up making movies
together everybody's off doing their own
thing now for the most part and they're
all successful in their own right but we
all got together for that one little
piece of time we are going to make that
and I think you have to also recognize
that sometimes there are going to be
moments where you don't ever get that
opportunity back like I'm so glad I did
that movie because I would never have a
lot of the things that I have today
because of that movie actually and one
of your questions was going to be about
the American night or the finger man on
a lot of thing that legitimize me in a
lot of people's eyes and it got me a lot
of jobs and got me in a lot of doors I
probably wouldn't be able to get into
otherwise even though it wasn't even
like a big deal really I mean I'll tell
you talk about that later but be a
finger man was a huge learning
experience and I still watch it today
I'm still happy with that film I think I
was like one of the most fun times in my
life was a good time wait also is one of
the most educational
you